Black Friday the official kickoff to the
holiday shopping season and no other
town doesn't quite as good as this one
now let's get out there really need a
new TV look they had the new 75 inch
tegu all just smart LED TV for 75% off
oh yeah you won the first 10 shoppers in
the store on Black Friday and that's
never gonna happen well why not we have
just much of a shot as anybody else I'm
the number one shopper in America
three years running I'm gonna buy all
ten of those TVs I'm Sol moneybags I'm
clear
don't be a hero Justin just give up
ever since I was a little boy I knew I
was good at one thing getting things on
sale look I know your dad died trying to
get a discman for 65% off in 94 it
wasn't worth it was it you are not your
father it's time for you to finally come
out of the shadows
let's what I have to do you're oz
Meredith you got the blu-ray player for
97 percent off back in 2012 that was a
long time ago I shop online huh we need
you I need you you start too long you
need to be a tip-top sack how you
turkeys same Cyber Monday
this is the main show you need the
cameras off together how fast can you go
tit even you just oughta try Craigslist
give me a light bulb
now VHS no again now you cooking it's
about finesse you trampled the mannequin
you trampled the shop and we don't
trample people well you don't need to
elbow focus breathe
great today where you going mom wants to
know for coming home for Thanksgiving
dinner tomorrow I've got bigger plans
Brian happened to you life life happened
to me you were never built for the rate
of sales Justin no all dreams and no
fineness is Justin this is Black Friday
when you were born I promised your
father that if anything ever happened to
him
do you get it I did keV
[Music]
eyes eyes wake up that's it I'm done
it's not over oz would have wanted it oz
is dead I can't do this alone
you're not alone come join me I would
rather play call of duty on a 32-inch
standard definition television with
several broken pixels
[Music]
to
you grant it in you all along did yours
as a beeper
this is about to you this is about the
man beside you will never be better than
when you are busting doors with your
brother
[Music]
find somebody you can trust you can't
put a price on their get discount there
there's no coupon friendship zone that's
not the same
so get in there and kick Hojo's
greatness friendship and the 75 inch to
go ultra TV
when it's what you got and it's what it
is this is how we ride this is how we
live
James what it takes to be the best man
it's here it's here
what get it there Patrick got it get it
get it you get it it's here quick